desde que las municiones rusas empezaron
a golpear edificios residenciales como
este en heart con el escuadrón
antibombas de la ciudad ha estado
desplazándose de una zona a otra
despejando y desarmando una por una las
pequeñas bombas que los proyectiles
esparcen por zonas densamente pobladas
recibimos una llamada de que se había
encontrado un objeto sospechoso en la
calle de tractor o whitney que alrededor
del 40 por ciento de estas submuniciones
no explotan al caer al suelo pero
podrían hacerlo en cualquier momento así
que el peligro está en todos lados está
cayó en un parque infantil la metralla y
los proyectiles son retirados y luego
van a parar a las afueras de la ciudad
desde el comienzo de la guerra hemos
estado extrayendo partes de los
explosivos de las calles de hardcore
aquí en particular se puede encontrar
partes de misiles huracán y es mersch
esto es lo que utilizan sobre nuestras
tropas pero hubo casos en que estas
bombas de racimo alcanzaron casas calles
de la ciudad y a la población civil
como muestran estas imágenes las bombas
de racimo están hechas para extenderse
por grandes áreas están formadas por una
cáscara hueca que se rompe en pleno
vuelo dejando escapar docenas o incluso
cientos de bombas más pequeñas llamadas
bombetas en todo craneal las cáscaras
exteriores de estas bombas de racimo
marcan el paisaje una señal de la
destrucción a la que condujeron la
oficina del alto comisionado de la onu
para los derechos humanos ha recibido
informes creíbles de que las fuerzas
rusas han utilizado municiones de racimo
incluso en zonas pobladas los ataques
indiscriminados están prohibidos por el
derecho internacional humanitario cerca
de 100 países en el mundo acordaron en
2008 un tratado que prohíbe las
municiones de racimo debido al daño
indiscriminado que infligen perú ucrania
eeuu y rusia se han negado a firmarlo